credo che sia il menù più esplicativo da
quando esiste posso cliccar e vediamo le
opzioni
non fa niente andiamo su play ragazzi
vediamo cosa ci posso fare play no sì
posso fare play off
e va beh siamo partiti ragazzi dove vi
faranno entro giusto quindi bene a tutti
i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono poi geo diciamo su vorrei
poter morire ma sai non sentito quindi
può così questo video un po un po strano
peccato questo gioco c'è un tizio che
non promette bene lì alla portineria ma
non fermiamoci pure vada avanti salve
mila posso parcheggio qua è ok non ho
ben capito ma possiamo posso entrare mi
scusi
certo se n'è andato
a si apre rapporto che preferite salve
dove le uscite shlein se ne andrà dove è
andato era qua prix un secco non puoi
uscire non ci sono porto ha fatto uscire
va bene comunque io continuerei ad
andare in macchina non so perché siamo
scesi nava che ha proprietà privata va
bene allora è a questo punto approcciamo
alla non so cos'è la fattoria al fatto
ok posso entrare giorno io entrerei qua
se mi fate il piacere per favore grazie
gentilissimi posso anche chiudere la
porta gentile va bene
c'è qualcuno a casa ho bisogno di aiuto
beh ti sei tu fermato con la macchina
sei tu un [ __ ] effettivo se devo
proprio di essere sincero almeno siamo
sinceri su ste cose c'è ed è colpa tua
ragazzi se preso un sacco di volte col
tasto sinistro c'è da un sacco di pugni
ma è roba
bellissimo è una casa di legno ci
potresti sfondare la porta con un due
tre calci ben piazzali pro
chissene fresco quasta una porta o
rubiamo questo
ho sentito un rumore se
c'è qualcuno che mi sta bussando la
è chiuso bisogno di trovare la chiave e
ho capito non è questo il mio problema
in questo momento sto sentendo rumori ma
fammi vedere fuori
tua madre surina grazie c'è un suino
cioè il suino e non me lo aspettavo
comunque mi sa dire per caso vabbè non
si può guardare in faccia suino cuoce
del sangue sembra essere blocca la cosa
nella partita granny questa ma che è
tutto chiuso dovrai chiavi per i porci
ho trovato un porco ma non il piede tra
thor
quando si dice i porci volano
effettivamente ma è morto da solo è
morto un maiale ma stai dormendo spero
anno e vivo che è posto mica mi sono
cagato addosso florino
che che cos'è salve
c'è un tizio qua
prendo questo prendo lasciano la chiave
la chiave grazie
è rinsavito il maiale va bene fratello
condivido un sacco la tua idea di
prendere di fare pisolini a caso per
terra però sembra un po un posto dove
non farli attenzione perché li hanno
ucciso qualcuno non fare la stessa fine
che mi stai simpatico
basta dire le cose ho trovato la kercher
o cielo c'è un e l'inventario dover
inventare ce l'ho trovato una chiave
cielo a meno che non sia la chiave del
ripostiglio anche sono per questo sta
sempre qua
a meno che non sia la chiave del
ripostiglio
hanno forse la chiave di casa che pirla
prova a entrare ftr sarà qualcosa in
casa perche permesso
ci stava c'è un tipo morto fuori
diventasse un quaderno e mail bello
lavandino pulito
in tutto questo dovrei trovare non so un
piede di porco cosa per aprire la porta
la dinamica di muoverà la barricata mia
moglie ha la chiave per la dinamite e
tua moglie moglie
guardiamoci pure un documentario su the
ring che mi sembra mi sembra il caso
e entrato qualcuno sono io che non lo
sono sognato credo che sia entrato
qualcuno ragazzi non ne sono
completamente sicuro prima sfondato la
finestra
ok guarda che disastro sono entrato un
minuto in casa e quindi
niente non spaccare la finestra bene
allegro ottimo mia moglie la chiave di
tutto dove mia moglie
io l'ho spericolati come le benne lavo
le mani me ne lavo completamente le mani
non ho ben capito
a si può spegnere la radio questo
gnocchi the
mastico mari che sento la
capitana porca porca
o
devi stare carta ammazzo da marco la
torcia da mata tiro in testa in una
testata che bullona guarda dove la
moglie
no è morto ormai endemica non l'ha
ucciso ti prego ogni volta vado a
controllare e sveglio sveglia posto
importante che sia sveglio la chiave
cela la moglie penso che la dinamica sia
qua dentro dove la moglie non è che la
moglie proprio satana e quindi è quello
il motivo
[Musica]
arrivederci poi guardi ti tieni d'occhio
tu perché io non ho voglia grazie ho
visto scene che non avrei dovuto vedere
però la chiave cela lei guardi non
vorrei disturba solo la chiave mi serve
solo quella
sarà la chiave vi prego ok
la chiave grazie
arrivederci
ma dall'altro c'è il senso a parte fatto
che qua come ci è arrivata la moglie qua
dove la prima non va bene la moglie a
posto mi serve adesso con la chiave apro
il l'armadietto per forza questo qua
bene dinamite
proprio lei
max horror
che sito rumore che sento
sempre tutti temi sempre d'occhio la
zona perché qua un casino è allora devo
far saltare in aria tutto sto bordello
qua per farlo devo piazzarla dinamite
qui innanzitutto perché
la vita un attimo ma spesso pensa di
dover accendere miccia tutto niente
mica che timing beh non ha fatto il
rumore dell'esplosione però lo se c'è
l'ho sentita nel cuore l'importante
questo permesso vara il posto più sicuro
finora e sono stai fogne e pensate come
sto messo a
cioè del sangue
no
aiuto se va bene allora pazza mi fermo a
sei anche tu fan dei me contro te non lo
è ok
thanks for download di e plaining di
short demo tubi continue non lo so però
grazie per aver reso la mia vita
migliore davvero non so come
ringraziarmi spero che ai video vi sia
piaciuto come se i ragazzi se vi sia
piaciuto al momento mi piace mi dispiace
per i job seeker gratuiti però
l'importante è che il suino si sia
salvato i suini si sono salvate se non
senatori si iscriverà come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video e ragazzi
[Musica]